156 years ago president abraham lincoln
launched nevada into statehood
he fought to make the silver state
official as the country fought a civil
war
everything about this place is battle
born so it only seems right that bitter
rivals unr
and unlv use brute force to capture the
cannon
oh there it is it's been red for two
years made its way home
where the desert meets the hills also
it's halloween in las vegas thanks for
not disappointing
nevada reno their offense did not
disappoint either
carson strong deep shot to romeo dubs
romeo where are we romeo in the insult
65 yard touchdown 17-6
tried shakespeare just didn't work final
minutes of the first half unlv unleashed
in 11-play
81-yard drive capstone by touchdown by
tailee collins but
the wolf pack answered strong to justin
lockhart
24-12 that was the score after one
unlv fought much improved from last week
max gillum to stevie jenkins making it a
one score game in the third quarter
and then the pack march back all the way
down the field to the promised land
touchdown 37-19 the cannon is going
north kevin martin was at allegiance
stadium and saw an improved unlv team
fall to high-powered nevada reno
good evening kevin
well good evening john yes as you
mentioned unlv falls
37-19 to unr in their first ever game
here at allegiance stadium of course the
fremont cannon now heading
up to reno now after two years here in
las vegas and
really as we just saw in those
highlights unlv had no answer
for reno's passing game carson strong
throwing for 350 yards and two
touchdowns
the rebels also committing 10 penalties
for 77 yards
you're not going to win any games marcus
arroyo will definitely have to
address that issue and clean that up in
the future but
my biggest takeaway tonight was there
were so many questions heading into this
one
around the quarterback position and we
got our answer tonight
max gillum stepped in he looked
confident he looked poised
throwing for 207 yards and two
touchdowns
very impressed with the seniors play
here today and
giving the fans something to cheer about
the few that were in attendance 2000 as
we mentioned
earlier now the rebels fall to 0-2 on
the season for the first time
since 2015. next up for the rebels
they'll host fresno state next saturday
here at allegion stadium and speaking of
those fans now orco mana is standing by
and he spoke with a few of the fans that
had the pleasure of seeing allegion
stadium for the first time and watching
the rebels here tonight hey orco
[Music]
well kevin what a historic night this is
the first time that football fans could
be here inside a legion stadium
due to cover 19 restrictions only about
2 000 of the 65 thousand seats were
filled
and even though that's the case even
though the rebels lost unlv fans tell us
they were just thrilled to be here it
was really
pretty neat it didn't seem like you're
in las vegas it seemed like we went out
of town to go see a pro football game or
something is it beautiful
just a beautiful stadium it was more
amazing than i thought it would be
it was really first class and right up
there with vegas
from what i saw it was about the safest
place i've been in the last eight months
you heard it there people feeling safe
definitely a fun night for everyone some
fans we spoke to actually said
that they hope that the capacity limit
will be even more so
we'll see if that changes in the future
but really a really exciting night for
football fans here at legion stadium
john we're going to toss it back to you
in the studio
thanks so much and yeah everybody there
was just happy to be at a football game
a live sporting event for some it's
the first time in about seven months